There was an explosion here, a strong first explosion
began to come out, the door was jammed
immediately after a minute or two. Probably after
2 minutes there was a strong second
explosion that flew straight into the corridor with the door.
it may even have burst a
hole here,
here is a view from above,
here there was a store, it’s not there
right in the middle of the yard, one bay and the second
bay here, if you can see the
destruction of the Ukrainian people
and are hooked, you must understand that the
criminal undertaking is a wicked shovan and the
first three creatures were very strong, I
went down to  the basement then there was a very
strong explosion 2
such a strong blast wave, everyone
flew out the windows
, you could see the fire, you could hear the smell of this,
I don’t know such a scorched something
[applause]